bonjour jean de gliniasty merci de
répondre à nos questions sur l' art et
france qu'est ce qu'il faut attendre de
ce rendez vous aujourd'hui à genève
alors je pense que la situation
militaire n'était pas encore tout à fait
mûr pour qu'on arrive à une négociation
dans l'hypothèse la plus positive
on pourrait imaginer que l'azerbaïdjan
cherche à prendre des gages territoriaux
pour obliger en quelque sorte l'arménie
à négocier donc est déjà un signe
positif c'est que pashinian s'est montré
prêt à négocier
on sait que la communauté internationale
et c'est pas très souvent que c'est le
cas c'est à dire etats unis russie
europe en la présence de la france
poussent à la négociation mais je pense
que l'azerbaïdjan veut d'abord prendre
un gage territoriale suffisant pour
négocier en position de force mais
genève c'est un début genève c'est un
début et le ministre arménien des
affaires étrangères et lui a tendu lundi
à moscou pour le moment on assiste à des
négociations séparées
comment m erevan et bakou autour de la
table écouter de toute façon le groupe
de minsk reste qu'il ya deux cadres
possible en fait concrètement il ya un
cadre d'un groupe de minsk qui serait
ensuite avalisé par le conseil de
sécurité
et puis un deuxième quart concrètement
c'est le cadre j'allais dire russo turcs
parce que les turcs ont introduit une
nouvelle dimension dans le conflit une
nouvelle dimension qui est à la fois
dangereuse qui est aussi le gérable pour
la russie on sait que la russie a pris
l'habitude de négocier avec la turquie
dans des situations où elle était
opposée à ce pays que ce soit en syrie
que ce soit en libye et c'est donc la
deuxième option sait aussi que ces
négociations soient j'allais dire sous
l'influencé un petit peu de la russie
d'un côté et de la turquie de l'eau vous
parlez de la turquie de la russie on
sait qu'il ya également paris washington
mais justement paris moscou et
washington le groupe de minsk 1-1 face à
ankara soutient de bakou quel est le
moyen de pression de la turquie face à
ces trois là justement parce que la
turquie est seul face à trois noms
j'avais peut-être face à troyes mais sur
le terrain elle livre des armements
elle a fait semble-t-il fait passer des
des troupes venues de syfy djihadistes
sans doute donc c'était là hélas
beaucoup de cartes en main et en fait il
faudra un moment si l'azerbaïdjan veut
négocier qui le bac ils s'entendent avec
la turquie en disant monde c'est parfait
maintenant on arrête
en quoi le haut karabagh et ils
stratégique pourquoi les les deux
parties arménie azerbaïdjan veulent dans
ce territoire depuis trente ans on le
rappelle il ya des pipelines des
hydrocarbures présents dans la région
je crois que c'est avant tout une
question nationale
le haut karabakh est peuplée d'arméniens
il a toujours été peuplée d'arméniens il
a toujours demandé son indépendance même
dans le cadre des républiques
socialistes soviétiques d'arménie et
d'azerbaïdjan
donc c'est avant tout une question
nationale
cela dit force est de constater que le
haut-karabakh domine une zone qui est
riche en pétrole riche en en tube de
tout genre et que si on arrivait à un
stade j'ai à dire ultérieure et plus
grave du conflit a cependant là les
infrastructures pétrolières pourraient
être menacés c'est pour ça que toute la
communauté internationale a intérêt à
trouver une solution
quid de la situation humanitaire 75000
personnes déplacées ans l'a appris hier
les autorités arméniennes communique
beaucoup sur les pertes mais pas les
autorités azéries pourquoi parce que
pour l'instant ce sont les essentiels
mans les populations arméniennes qui
sont bombardés
defacto
mais au niveau de la situation
humanitaire qu'en est il réellement
moi je n'ai pas de deux comme l'âge de
moyens de juger je ne suis pas allé sur
le terrain mais il est clair que vu
l'intensité des bombardements
la question des réfugiés se pose spe
canal c'était pas la carte est sous une
sous une avalanche de domicile de
bombardements et donc les gens fuient
c'est malheureusement la logique atroces
de la guerre est ce que vous êtes
optimiste concernant un cessez-le-feu à
court terme ou a contrario ce que vous
pensez qu'on conflit peut s'intensifier
encore plus en gros qu'est ce qui va se
passer selon vous ces prochains jours
alors le conflit atteint une dimension
qui n'existait pas jusqu'à présent
c'était un conflit local et jusqu'à
présent en gros la russie réussissait à
maintenir un cessez le feu
cela dit on peut dire que ça fait assez
longtemps quand même qu'on pouvait
imaginer que l'azerbaïdjan et notamment
ilham aliev ne pourrait se contenter de
cette situation
ce dock la légitimité de de la dynastie
aliev repose un peu sur la reconquête du
karabakh c'est consubstantiel en quelque
sorte au pouvoir azéri donc donc je
encore une fois je pense que
l'azerbaïdjan
peut-être ne veut pas reconquérir le
haut karabakh est en tout cas veut
répond qu il reconquérir
absolument et ça c'est un but de guerre
est essentielle
l'ensemble de territoire proprement
azerbaïdjanais qui entoure le haut
karabakh et qui ont été conquis par les
arméniens
en 94 et d'une fois qu'il raconte hisse
à ce moment là ça se posera donc je ne
pense pas car tu court terme il y aura
des négociations ou à très court terme
en tout cas je pense que l'azerbaïdjan
va d'abord prendre des gages et que le
premier enjeu ça sera la récupération de
cette couronne de territoire qui est
proprement azerbaïdjanaise et une fois
que ces gages rond été pris je pense que
les azerbaïdjanaises imagine que
pashinian et les arméniens seront
j'allais dire plus ouverts à la
négociation il est de fait qui ne l'ont
pas été ces dernières années
merci jean de gliniasty d'avoir répondu
à nos questions genre est directeur de
recherche à l'iris l'institut des
relations internationales et
stratégiques et spécialiste des
relations internationales